hello and welcome no tea no tea nope
three - three - I'm ready now I'm still
ready three two one start
Nick maybe you should just include that
it was gold Oh
[Music]
welcome to D Rankin job or is very
pretty figure that Dear John and Hank
it's a comedy podcast in which two
brothers answer your questions and give
you dubious advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John how are you doing today I
am doing well Hank the sun is shining
here in indianapolis it's still kind of
cold and I'm a little over it but I'm
doing well
I am happy to be alive I'm grateful to
be a Midwestern ER it's a good day to
live in the middle of the world's 14th
best country as measured by life
expectancy I am I recently found out
that my employees have been making fun
of me because I put a nose in my smiley
faces Oh like a little dot my emoticon
smiley faces first of all I do not emoji
very much no me neither I was raised in
a world where we created our own emojis
using whatever tools we had at our
disposal and we called those emoticons
and that's not the same as an emoji and
when people call them emojis I get
offended but apparently it's okay to
just do a colon parenthesis for a smiley
face but :
- parentheses they find to be a sign
that I am NOT with the times I in
general yeah I've that emoticons can
express the full range of human emotion
thereby rendering emojis unnecessary I
completely agree with you about that
however you are wrong that emoticons
need noses also I have an update Hank
and it's not a good one okay what's
update the United States ranks 31st in
life expectancy well well uh let's see
where Mizzou is on the list because I
feel like I feel like we do better than
the US as a whole you should move here
we're behind Chile and Costa Rica and
Slovenia those are our immediate the
people we immediately want to beat and
then we're just ahead of the Czech
Republic in the Maldives oh okay I don't
know very much about those places or the
world but I know about my ability
American noses so let's get back let's
get back to areas where I'm an expert
which is that this is how it's done and
that's fine I don't you can't I'm doing
it my way and I think it looks better
and I think all your weird noseless
faces look disturbing and I just think
of happy Voldemort I remember the first
time I saw an emoticon like back on
CompuServe in the early 90s and I
remember people would explain to me it's
a sideways smiley face and I would look
and all I could see for the life of me
was a colon and a closed parenthesis and
it took me the longest time to be like I
literally as I recall at least 14 year
old me had to turn his head 90 degrees
to be like oh yeah I guess I kind of see
it oh man yeah well that makes a certain
amount of sense it is very
representational speaking of children
Hank would you like a short poem for
today okay this short poem is by I
believe his name is Niall age six it's
been making the rounds on Twitter it's
very very good
and it's called the tiger it's written
by a six year old boy and it's called
the tiger and it's about death but it's
also about life and hope and also
despair the tiger he destroyed his cage
yes yes the tiger is out the tiger bite
by Nile age six yes yes it's just
perfect the Tigers out I think I
understand that poem John
I don't think either of us can
understand it in its full complexity cuz
it's the tiger Nile I don't know if the
tiger is Nile or if the cage is Nile oh
man what or if the tiger is just a tiger
there is always the possibility that the
tiger is just a tiger oh man do you want
to answer some questions from our
listeners John yeah Hank let's answer
some questions from our listeners this
first one comes from a player who writes
Dear John and Hank I have recently come
into possession of the American cheese
Society 2010 second place ribbon I now
have the ability to unilaterally declare
someone or something the second best
cheese in the year of 2010 how do I
wield this power responsibly I don't
know anything about cheese my friend
makes cheese but it's terrible so it
seems dishonest to give it to him you
actually have someone who in your life
who's a cheese a cheese maker
well you you're denying that person
Jesus so bad that you feel dishonest
yeah well there you go Blair's a very
honest person how do I make sure I don't
go crazy with this power Bri afraid
Blair first off where I just want to
correct you about one thing which is
that you say in your question I now have
the ability to unilaterally declare
someone or something the second best
cheese for the year 2010 in fact you
only have the unilateral ability to
declare someone or something the second
best American cheese for the year 2010
mm-hmm what is very very different
because as everyone knows America is
31st in cheese I believe that is correct
yes just just behind Costa Rica John is
it a thing that we are now going to have
to do where you and I compete to be the
best cheese of 2010 or is that nothing
no we can't compete with each other
that's not part of our brand our brand
is collaboration and mutual admiration
yeah our brand is I really
appreciate your AFC Wimbledon news you
really appreciate my Mars news even if
deep down were probably checking Twitter
right it's funny because we started out
trying to make fun of each other's news
but the listeners hated that because
they liked the collaboration and mutual
appreciation so if anything we need to
lobby Blair to have both of us named Co
second best cheese of America in 2010
unfortunately there needs a second
ribbon well or take can you take your
ribbon to like a place that does laser
cutting and just slice it perfectly down
the middle so John and I can share it or
perhaps I'm just gonna throw this out
there
a ribbon making factory and just make a
second ribbon mmm
you can't just make a best cheese ribbon
John this is the second best American
cheese of 2010 if you just went and made
a second best American cheese of 2010
ribbon that would not allow Blair the
ability I've got a few us though that
upon everyone in America I've got a few
ideas for this thing my first idea is
Blair you could give it to your
significant other if you have one and
then when it come comes time to break up
with them instead of saying like I think
we need to break up you could just say
um I'm gonna need that ribbon back good
you are you are now not the second best
chief what if you just went to the
grocery store and like put it on a
cheese just like a Kraft singles I mean
the nice thing about bestowing it upon
your significant other until and unless
right it's really cool is that you get
to keep it in the you know you get to
keep it in the family more or less
that's the only thing I'd say Blair this
is such a powerful wonderful thing
that's come into your life don't let it
go easy you know like make sure that
when you bestow it upon someone or
something they understand that this is
temporary and that at any moment
something or someone new might become
the
and best American cheese of 2010 there
is it possible that you're the best
cheese of 2010 second best sorry Blair
is it possible that you're the second
best cheese of 2010 like that why you
got it like the universe delivered it to
you because of our quality cheesiness
you're so right Hank Blair you've
already won it's just that you haven't
yet accepted the victory Blair no you
you don't know you don't know yet that
you were once the second best to use in
America that's right what you really
need to do Blair is you need to look in
the mirror and realize that you've been
looking and looking and looking for the
second best American cheese of 2010 but
all the while it's been within you and
you need to pin that ribbon on your
sweater because it's you Blair you did
it just daily affirmations walking
around I am a powerful human I love
myself I have had a positive impact upon
the world I am the second best American
cheese of 2010 you know how that
question when you finish can I just say
one more thing okay I suppose you know
how when you finish a marathon or in my
case a half marathon they give you a
like a medal and you wear that medal all
day but you can't really wear it into
the next day because it becomes a little
weird like at some point if 35 days
later you're still wearing your medal
people are like well so you finished a
half marathon a month ago the second
best cheese of 2010 is nothing like that
where you can wear that ribbon every day
for the rest of your life this next
question comes from Ashley who asks dear
Hank and John I will be getting married
soon and therefore have been on the
receiving end of many gifts that I
picked out myself I'm very thankful for
all of the gifts but I'm at a loss when
writing thank-you notes how do you thank
someone for a gift that you picked out
yourself normally I would comment on how
much I like the gift but in this case
that feels like I'm complimenting myself
how do I show genuine appreciation
without giving fake compliments also the
wedding is March 10th and we'll be in a
much more interesting
of Arkansas than the clothing store in
the middle of a field if either of you
would like to come toasters and tuxedos
Ashley heck I actually think I have some
good advice here because I've written a
fair few thank you notes for wedding
presents that Sarah and I picked out and
here is this was initially something
that I I felt uncomfortable with and
Sarah explained it to me
thusly and I think she was correct she
said what you say in the thank-you note
is what you are going to use the gift
more in your new shared life well you
tell a story about how that that person
is going to impact and has affected your
life and that that is it that is a the
best like a lot of times the best thanks
is like letting people not just saying
thank you but saying thank you and and
then this is how you have made my life
better what what Katherine and I did is
we laser etched the name of the person
who gave us each of the gifts on the
gift so that we have to think about them
every time we use it real and and so
like our mixer is named Ashley and our
like every one of our Forks set just has
the name of my parents Sydney and Mike
on it is that rum so no no I was gonna
say that's a really lovely idea but yeah
you thank the person for for what this
gift is going to do for your life and
then you transition to thanking the
person for whatever they have done for
you in your life which I actually think
should be the focus of the thank-you
note is finding a way to say thank you
uncle Beck's for all of the great times
in Vermont and the wisdom that you've
shared with me and the kindness that you
showed me and how welcome you've made me
feel in your family yeah good good point
John I like it a lot this next question
comes from Tanya who writes Dear John
and Hank my university is overwhelmed
with giant crows throughout the year and
I want to befriend them so I can have a
beautiful intelligent and slightly
terrifying animal companion I've heard
they remember human faces well Tanya you
are freaking me out right now I'm just
gonna tell you the truth man I'm I'm
gonna freaked out
why are you freaked out by okay
they just start the question over
because maybe he didn't weren't
listening my university is overwhelmed
with giant crows throughout the year and
I want to befriend them so I can have a
beautiful intelligent and slightly
terrifying animal companion I've heard
they remember human faces well I mean
have you have you read Maggi Steve
otters Raven cycle yes what it's called
yes yeah
that also freaks me out I think that
it's great I I'm curious if these are
crows or if they are Ravens actually
because they do you know the difference
between a raven and a crow Jon I bet I'm
about to find out so if you see a crow
you'll think to yourself I wonder if
that's a crow or a raven if you see a
raven you will think to yourself I have
been deeply seen and I'm afraid of that
gigantic animal is so true so true
that's a great point anyway Tanya goes
on to ask should I follow the rules and
not feed the birds or should I be a
rebel and follow my dreams of having
strange animal friends if I feed them
what else can I do to make them my
friends I thought my question might be
relevant to your podcast because crows
are symbols of death thank you Tom yeah
yeah I mean here's the thing Tanya don't
feed the Ravens don't feed that don't
feed that corvids in general don't feed
any of the wildlife on your on your
school campus there are other better
ways to make them your friends I the
number one way that I would recommend is
bitching well how to befriend I mean I
typed in how to befriend and that the
number one thing is a crow and I don't I
don't know does Google because they hear
me right now does it know what I'm
talking about that so like oh my god it
oh my god you're not kidding
I know apparently this is the thing how
does this happen oh my god I'm so
freaked out it's Google Hank what the
flip just happened we just we both
googled how did befriend and the first
Google suggestion was oh maybe that was
the thing people mostly prefer
and a human the Frick so like we have
now determined that humans would rather
be friends with crows than people dogs
elephants any other animal themselves of
cats just gross
I don't know maybe befriend is a
specific word that like you don't say I
would like to do you befriend a young
lass now well I mean but you would have
yet why why a crow why not lid I am so
freaked out I can't even talk why not
literally any other animal species I
don't know the question is can you can
you make friends with the corvid by
without food and probably not but they
do like other stuff so maybe and the
good news is that apparently enough
people have searched for this that I'm
sure people who are looking to optimize
their their blogs for search engines
have have written theirs in fact a
reddit thread right here there's also on
a location how to make friends with
crows and on coyote dot s so coyotes
with a dot in it also making friends
with crows on the corvid blog on the
coyotes blog network this this reddit
thread it has a number of suggestions so
I don't know I didn't look this up
because I didn't actually expect that
there would be a great deal of
information on it but it turns out
you're not the only one you're in fact
in the majority of people who wish to
become friends with a blank
ah yeah I mean I love this didn't we
have a question or maybe I just read
this somewhere from a person who who
like the crows think that he's their
neighbor and I like it's like bringing
like this guy presents because his
neighbor is feeding the growth I'm not
even in my body right now because I'm so
freaked out I can't remember the past
the for the future or the present I I
just googled how to befriend uh and the
first suggestion was crow I mean are you
using a Google pixel right now no I'm
using my my computer to normal
no you know I guess it's a computer they
say are you talking to me on a Google
pixel the phone no I don't even know
what is the name of your phone
that's an iPhone 5s so okay now with
that that's just it's just that you
don't know what phones are called that's
fine I'm on a Google pixel cell like now
I'm like I said are they listening but
you're all the way over there on your
iPhone 5s so I don't know how Google
would have this information about you
unless my phone is like he's talking to
John Green John Green is googling and
Indianapolis they're talking about crows
quick give them crow results I don't
think that that's what happened but I'm
not putting it past the next the level
of dystopia that we're headed into this
next question comes from Deb who writes
Dear John and Hank I recently purchased
a humidifier to keep my skin happy in
the winter and a thought occurred to me
as I began to use it what would happen
if I put P in this humidifier Deb it
turns out this is only the second or
third weirdest thing I've heard today
well I'm awaiting your responses I I
guess I should emphasize Hank that like
there might be no animal on earth I want
to be friends with less than a crow like
okay while I am awaiting your responses
I promise I will not test it out in the
meantime vote for Pedro Deb oh well I
Hank
suddenly we have a tremendous amount of
responsibility because it is up to us
whether Deb puts pee in the dehumidifier
or wait is it a humidifier or
dehumidifier I believe it's a humidifier
yes that does make more sense okay um
Hank what happens if you put heat pee in
a humidifier I'm not a scientist you are
this I mean it's don't put pee in a
humidifier what's gonna happen is the
most but not all of what's gonna come
out of your humidifier is gonna be water
but there probably will also be some
ammonia that comes out and that's not
going to smell good because ammonia is
one of the more volatile meaning it's
more it evaporates more easily so
basically your humidifier is trying to
create evaporation
and to evaporate water and in that
process it will evaporate other things
that have lower boiling points than
water like ammonia and so your room will
probably smell somewhat like ammonia as
that ammonia off gases the urine the
urea is in equilibrium with ammonia so
more ammonia will be created and that
will continue to create more and more
ammonia until all of the urea has been
converted into ammonia or until all of
the water is gone at which point the
urea will fall out of solution and
become a solid along with a lot of other
solids that are in your that are
dissolved in in urine and that will clog
up to your humidifier and your
humidifiers filter and you'll have to
replace the filter much more quickly so
basically don't do that but at least you
know why hey Hank do you know what the
first thing that Google auto fills if
you google what happens if I pee in is
what humidifier no it's gas tank it's
got oh thank goodness
oh good lord yeah can I pee in a cup and
test it later for pregnancy day can I
pee in a policeman's hat well it's
certainly not recommended I mean I guess
it depends on if you want to go to jail
I mean if you like order one online like
get a policeman's hat on Amazon from a
costume yeah thank you people if you
want to do that that's maybe a line from
something wait I read recently that a
pregnant woman has the legal right to
urinate in a policeman's helmet it's
it's a question to the Guardian
newspaper however at this year's dawning
Hill Carnival all officers refused my
girlfriend this honor on what grounds
can they refuse such a request Wow
my favorite response to this by a
country mile is somebody who this was a
British published in a British newspaper
and my favorite response by a country
mile is from Barry
who wrote surely you must be taking the
piss this is high-quality berry
packingtown yeah good stuff berry
alright let's move on to the next
question if anybody knows a berry
packingtown in Nassau in the Bahamas
just give him a pat on the back for us
we appreciated that can't we just go
hard not weird for the rest of the
bottle please
turn into like deep normal just a
180-degree turn back toward normal I
mean it was all fun and games when it
was just about Blair and her cheese's
okay this next question comes from Jake
who asks dear Hank and John
so I sitting in my math class today and
I was talking to my friend next to me
when she began to yawn I felt it almost
instinctual to look away as she covered
her mouth and then this raised the
question is it disrespectful to look at
someone while they're yawning I became
quite aware of this dilemma throughout
the rest of class and now I'm worried
that I'll somehow make someone feel
self-conscious if I do look dubious
advice is of course much appreciated
Jake I mean I think it's rather bad form
to look at someone for more than say
half a second ever what I mean no I mean
not if you're well yeah if you're
talking then no that's that is a good
interesting point John how long can you
look at someone if you're not like
currently in communication with them
without it being weird which is it that
long it's not that long it's less than a
second for sure yeah and I have in fact
found myself like being like I did that
for too long and I feel now an urge to
apologize which I will not indulge in
because that would make it even weirder
when someone honestly when someone looks
at me for longer than one second I
immediately say I'm the one who does
history my brother is the one who is in
your chemistry class I just say it I
don't even wait I did
one timely reason someone would look at
me for longer than a second I did that
one time and I have not I have not done
it since this occurred because the guy
then said no I need to get to my car
hmm well that's brutal that is a battle
it was about the worst that's up it was
a very diffused and and and I also that
guy I I've seen him around he works at a
restaurant in town and like no I can't
go there anymore
well maybe you can but you'll just be
forever known as the guy who wasn't as
famous as he fancied himself it's been
two years and I haven't been back to
that restaurant so I don't think the
reason you can't look at someone when
they're yawning is because they're
yawning I think it's because when
they're yawning you're like not in
conversation with them and so they're
having a private moment and so you avert
your eyes
this is what I do and admittedly I don't
make much eye contact when I am talking
to someone because I find it weird weird
and overwhelming but like yeah you avert
your eyes because they're having this
private moment and then when the
conversation re resumes you go back it
just occurred to me that resume z' is
there good zooms can can I google again
Hank if I've learned anything today it's
don't Google just go to Bing calm and
type in typing something this Bing
autofill B yeah I don't want to see your
auto with a friend okay you go to Bing
it says how do i befriend someone how do
i befriend somebody on facebook how do i
befriend somebody on snapchat that's
normal Bing you're a normal search
engine you don't freak me out at all
what was the question if you can resume
can you sue yeah probably but the point
is that once you resume conversation you
can resume eye contact and that's my
personal approach but I'm not sure that
I'm an expert in this field and I don't
make a lot of eye contact well it's also
that like I like I try not to yawn while
I'm talking to someone though I
understand that you can't always control
that eye and and it is sort of like a it
it's like there's a pause in the
discussion now and you're sort of like
okay it's this is the thing that's
happening and it will end a bodily
function is occurring and now it has
ended and we can resume conversation
apparently it means take in Latin
according to Rosie oh no whoo oh thank
you very much I very nearly tweeted that
question shot but I thank you too rez
the otter for saving me the trouble this
next question comes from Jamie who
writes Dear John and Hank who's
responsible for cleaning out the dryer
lint trap is it the person who is taking
their newly dried clothes out of the
dryer or the person putting their newly
washed clothes into the dryer I'm living
with roommates and I don't want this to
be a hangars facing outward or toilet
paper on backwards situation it won't
matter in the end Jamie you're right
Jamie it won't matter in the end because
of course we'll all be dead but if this
is something that matters it in the
middle yeah I check after I take my
clothes out I clean the screen and
before and when I'm about to dry clothes
I checked the screen it is not a
intensive chore the checking of the lint
screen and the cleaning of the lint
screen in fact I kind of like cleaning
the lint screen
I like I don't know how it comes off as
like a sort of like this like semi semi
solid like holding itself together like
weird piece of fabric that you can pull
apart and ball up and like I don't I
like it so I check every time personally
and I don't find it to be an onerous
task and occasionally they will be a
little bit unlit there and I'll be like
sweet I get to clean the lint tray yeah
I also find it enjoyable I think that my
rule of thumb is it's the person when
you're loading the dryer you load the
dryer and then you check the lint tray
and then you get started so I don't do
it when I'm emptying the dryer I do it
when I'm loading the dryer I will say
however that I once met someone who'd
collected years and years worth of their
dryer lint and it was a visually
impressive thing you really do build up
some dryer lint I've always like I like
like after after we dry the towels I
always like the dryer lint because it's
almost like a tiny towel yeah it has
like it's the same color and you know
it's the same fibers I why was this
person
collecting all the Thailand oh it was uh
I didn't get a great sense for why but
they didn't speak frankly they seemed
like the kind of person who would
collect years worth of dryer lint okay
okay sort of more of a character trait
than it than a project then they were
they were an artist I still are an
artist but yeah yeah a non-specific as
you can be which I pray that today's
podcast is in fact brought to you by
artistic eccentricity artistic
eccentricity is it inherent or is it
kind of a construct I'm not sure this
podcast is also brought to you by the
Tiger the tiger Niall is Niall the cage
is the tiger the cage the Tiger the
tiger is out but it's also in because
the tiger is also the cage and of course
today's podcast is brought to you by the
second best cheese in America from 2010
America's second-best 2010 cheese now
named Blair and the podcast is also
brought to you by deep normal deep
normal it's where we need to be headed
it strong too strong
turn into deep normal Jon dryer limp
this problem is probably a really good
good deep normal thing to discuss though
then you ended up an artistic
eccentricity and a several garbage bags
full of dryer lint
so I mean still faring well better than
making friends with crows which by the
way it's not that that's weird it's the
Google autofill thing that freaked me
out we also have a regular sponsor for
today's podcast and we're very grateful
to our friends at Squarespace
Squarespace of course is your all-in-one
shop for great websites including by the
way Hank green comm Hank Green's brand
new website where you can pre-order his
book an absolutely remarkable thing I
just inserted promo and our promo
Squarespace
also helped make the art assignment
website Squarespace made the website
that I use for my books John Green books
calm it's just an amazing amazing
tool and hosting service one-stop shop
for all of your web needs and it turns
out Ryan actually wrote us a question
what why do people want to have websites
well Ryan thanks for asking I made that
up but I could tell there are a lot of
people there are a lot of reasons that
you want when I have a website in you
know having your own domain name like a
place that is yours and not up like
something that exists on someone else's
platform you know it's your Twitter
account to your YouTube account having
someplace where all those things are
connected and you control them directly
is is is like to me it's a freedom
that's nice to have when when you can
have it
and also it's a way of showcasing all of
your things in one place and that might
just be sort of like a professional
portfolio that like it's almost like a
like a always resume that's sitting
there telling people a little bit about
you and and who you are and and giving
you lending some like professionalism to
you that might even be necessary and a
good thing to have even if you have a
job right now but also especially if
you're trying to work and build build
you know your life as an independent
creator of some kind whether that's like
an architect or a graphic designer
or you might I don't know you could bake
furniture you might be a teacher or an
instructor and wanna be you know having
like more information about you out
there that way so that people can find
out who you are and what you do and it's
like I've always had a personal website
it used to be that that was sort of the
only way you could be out there and it's
something that I've always been you know
been like sort of personally tied to
I've often thought that if I hadn't had
Hank as my brother aside from all of the
wonderful work that I wouldn't have been
able to do the stuff that we collaborate
on I don't know that I would have had a
career as a writer because Hank
did such a good job of designing my
early websites which helped me get some
of my early work make some of the early
connections that I made with Mental
Floss magazine and with the local and PR
station where I was living in Chicago
and stuff like that and with Squarespace
it's like you have a Hank because they
make it very very easy to design
and and make your website look extremely
professional you can go to Squarespace
comm right now and get a free trial when
you use the promo code Dear John or dear
Hank in fact I don't even use Hank
anymore I use Squarespace Squarespace
comm you can use dear Hank or Dear John
as your offer code and get 10% off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
thank you again to Squarespace for
sponsoring our podcast today and in
general for being so great at sponsoring
lots of podcasts and also making a cool
thing this next question John it comes
from josh o who asks dear Hank and John
why is it the computers always run
slower when they're first turned on I
always hear that they need to get warmed
up but is that a thing if it is why
aren't we just putting fuzzy socks and
knit hats on our computers are giving
them mugs of warm tea to help speed them
up when we turn them on Joshua Joshua
this is definitely it's it's a car thing
it's a machine thing that they can
operate better when they're warm because
the oil gets borås 'kiss you know your
catalytic converter doesn't work as well
unless it's heated up stuff like that is
where this phrase comes from but that is
not why your computer takes extra time
to get going at optimal speed before or
after it starts up that's because
there's a lot of things that happen when
your computer starts up and all those
things are happening like all those
programs are running they're opening
simultaneously lots of different things
are occurring and then once your
computer is booted up those things are
done happening and and you don't have to
your your programs that you're running
aren't competing for resources with
those things and that's why I often find
what I'm using my computer that it gets
really slow and then I'll go into my
task list and I'll notice that I have
you know 75 different programs running
at the same time and I'm always reminded
of this great onion point/counterpoint
they used to do this series called point
counterpoint where one person with one
perspective would write an editorial and
then right below that someone who
disagrees with write an editorial and
then you would have to decide who you
agree with and the point in this
particular one was written by an office
manager in the headline was my computer
hates me
and the counterpoint was written by the
computer and it was called I hate that
idiot
[Laughter]
and I always think about that I always
think like God why does my computer hate
me and then I go into my task list and
I'm like oh right it hates me because
I'm being so mean to it yeah I I was
once called to a friend's dorm room in
college to fix her computer and I opened
up her you know sort of like the hard
drive inspector and she had like 200
kilobytes of space left on her computer
and I was like where what why what have
you downloaded and it wasn't that she
had like you know like a hundred mp3s
but she had managed to download part of
like 4,000 songs no idea that she'd done
it right it was just like it like the
the Napster because this was the
monaster area the Napster like partial
song incomplete download folder was her
entire hard truth well man Napster it's
been a while my my computer currently
has seven gigs free out of 500 because
I'm always fighting a war against
wanting to preserve every movie clip I
have ever generated while making
vlogbrothers videos and also wanting my
computer to work that's an ongoing fight
that I've been having for 11 years now
well I'll tell you what John I gave up
that fight a long time ago and now just
delete everything all right Hank it is
time for the all-important news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon all right John
and the Mars news is pretty obvious this
week Elon Musk put three of his Falcon
nine boosters together into the Falcon
Heavy which has 27 boosters because I
just multiplied 9 by 3 and that is 20 27
engines that's a lot of thrust John and
was able to prove that this thing works
two of the Boosters landed on land they
came back they landed almost
simultaneously it was beautiful and
perfect
and I can't believe it the third the
central stage booster crashed into the
ocean not even very close to the drone
ship it was supposed to land on but two
out of three ain't bad and and the the
falcon heavy test flight contained
because why not a Tesla Roadster with a
man like a crash-test dummy in a
spacesuit on it and and that resulted in
some very good pictures and then the
that capsule did its secondary burn
which takes it out of the orbit of Earth
and into orbit around the Sun and that
the the idea was to get it roughly into
Mars's orbit though it wasn't going to
orbit Mars so it was going to be roughly
at the same distance from the Sun as
Mars going around the Sun not going
around Mars which would have required a
lot more careful telemetry and a lot
more communications equipment and so it
but instead it turned out that the
rocket had enough to get it past Mars's
orbit and it's headed for the asteroid
belt John it's out there now on its way
to the asteroid belt but we have proved
that the Falcon Heavy can deliver things
to Mars it just has to be more careful
and also that that this is the first
private spaceflight ever that has taken
anything out of Earth's orbit so that's
pretty remarkable so this means that
with current technology Elon Musk and
his company can get stuff to Mars that
is correct yes that's amazing I know
it's good to do this job to Mars or just
stuff right now they can only get people
they could only get stuff to Mars just
because the crew capsules have not been
built yet the Space Launch System which
is NASA's heavy rocket will have a crew
capsule that will be ready before the
Falcon is ready to launch people but the
way we're gonna get to Mars is not all
at once so it's not going to be
one like with Apollo you could get
everything on one rocket and you could
get the landing and return all of it on
one rocket that is not how we're gonna
get to Mars we're gonna have to send
things ahead of time to land on Mars so
that those things are up and running and
probably creating fuel from the Martian
atmosphere on the surface of Mars and
also the water on Mars theoretically
hopefully and and then and then the
astronauts will go after that stuff
happen so it is important to have a
heavy rocket that can send stuff other
than people it seems like it's gonna be
hard to do all of that by 2027 well you
know John the world is a great place
full of wonder and mystery and
unexpected successes so we'll just hold
on and see what happens
also unexpected failures I really liked
something Elon Musk said in the wake of
this because he did put his old Tesla
Roadster into orbit which is pretty cool
a quick question when it goes out into
the asteroid belt is it gonna get
pummeled by asteroids probably not
there's pretty empty out there but okay
several of my of people I follow on
Twitter we're like hey Eon can you share
the orbit data with us so we can see
because it isn't just like the question
of is it gonna hit something which
almost certainly it won't there's just
not a lot of stuff in space but also how
stable is its orbit going to be so it
could end up being influenced by the
gravity of Jupiter or doing a gravity
assist on a smaller asteroid or
something and and and its orbit might
change it might get sent out of the
asteroid belt it might be sent in closer
to this inner solar system in any case
it's not like a dangerous thing in
general he mostly it was like don't
actually hit Mars with this thing
because there's very specific protocols
for things that can land on other
planets and drived clinic cleanliness
and stuff so right they didn't want him
to actually hit Mars was the main
concern but it's pretty hard to actually
get into a planet because you you almost
always end up in orbit rather than
intersecting because it it actually
usually you have to slow down a lot for
your orbit to deteriorate enough that
you will enter a planet's atmosphere so
it's pretty hard to actually get a
planet no well I really like the quote
that he said after this he about putting
the Tesla into orbit it's kind of silly
and fun but I think that silly and fun
things are important and yeah that's so
true I I agree I agree
speaking of silly and fun things mm-hmm
I wish I had some to share Wow now AFC
Wimbledon unbeaten in January didn't
give up a single goal it was our month
this mere Ballas we just played
phenomenally and then in February it's
been a month is horrible us just
horrible lost to nil - I know I say this
wrong Rotherham Rotherham wrote wrote
her him brought whatever that team and
then we went to yesterday as we're
recording this we went to bury like you
know bury the bodies bu ry and it was a
makeup game there the bottom team in
league one or in the very bottom there
in last place
oh no we lost 2-1 very disappointing
yeah if you're new you're new you're new
foot hitting hitting the ball job no Joe
Pig it played the whole game he didn't
score a single goal very disappointing
so it's I don't know I hopefully fed
things are gonna take a turn for the
better in February we had such a
wonderful January and then February so
far has been terrible
fortunately the the Dons are is still
above the relegation zone while the
franchise applying its trade Milton
Keynes is still down there but it is
getting quite tight it's quite tight at
the bottom the Dons are in 19th and only
two points clear of Oldham who are
currently the first team in the
relegation zone so I don't know 16 games
left in the league one season
here's the basic situation Hank there's
16 games left and Wimbledon need from
those 16 games around 18 points
so if we could just win the next six
games we can do whatever we want in the
last ten but we do need to win six more
games all right how many games are there
I just said there were 16 there are 16
left but it's ok you're not the only one
not listening I the thing is John that I
was looking at this information that was
supplied to us by this remarkable person
who has created the bath bombardment
compartment yes we're gonna get to that
right now we need to read a couple
responses to things but before I get to
the extraordinary bath bombardment
compartment created by Liana or possibly
Liana I need to read this response from
Stacie who wrote Dear John and Hank in a
recent episode of the pod Sara shared
her method of tying laces where you wrap
the string around twice you wrap the
loop around twice well you know I'll put
a link to a video of it on the patreon
you can go to patreon.com/scishow John
you don't have to give money to see the
video or anything and you can see this
magical way of tying your shoes that
really is a game changer I recently got
new winter boots that kept coming untied
which is very annoying in a snowy
Canadian winter but I started using the
sara method and my life is changed
forever this is the ultimate shoe tying
method no question bring on winter and
it really is the ultimate shoe tying
method although I should say for the
record it is not the Sarah method Sarah
would like it to be clear that the as
far as she is concerned the credit for
this method should go to her cousin mark
so thank you Mark
I seen people do that and I didn't
realize there was a reason for it
I used to have shoes that just came
untied all the time and now I have shoes
that don't tie I gotten she used to have
like a drawstring basically and I feel
like I I feel like I live in the like
I'm like living in 30:18 John I'm it's
the future over here all right let's get
to this letter from Leanna all right
Leanna is a senior majoring in
bioengineering longtime listener of the
pod and has created a blog titled re
Hank and John in which I attempt to
implement
your dubious advice into my own life I
have had an amazing time getting out of
my comfort zone and trying you're
incredibly dubious advice so there is a
a blog it's a tree Hank and John blog
spot.com and the inaugural post to
rehang can John none other than creating
the bath bombardment and went swimmingly
well although it's a little rustic it is
indeed it is made of a clothes hanger
some rubber bands Tupperware that has a
lot of holes poked in it some some more
rubber bands and yeah you see what
happens the shower goes into the thing
and that it dissolves then you can take
a bath bomb with a shower this is so
much John that I ever thought possible I
mean this is even though it looks fairly
jerry-rigged together this is so much
better than I ever thought about
bombardment compartment could ever be
it's truly truly magnificent since then
Liana has gone on to attempt cereal dust
granola know another extraordinarily
dubious suggestion but it looks it looks
like she's had a great time this is a
wonderful wonderful blog re Hank and
John blog spot.com
if you're into the pod you'll be into
this yeah I thought mean the theory is
the cereal this granola looks great John
I think a spoiler alert
loved it Julianne loves the freaking
cereal just granola I like I think I
think that John we we might actually
have a lot of very good ideas on this
podcast oh god no don't encourage him
Liana but do keep up the good work
hey what did we learn today we learned
we learned that Blair is truly the
second best cheese of 2010 in America
and we also learned that it's okay to
befriend crows as long as you don't feed
them to make them your friends and also
we learned that apparently according to
Google lots of people want to befriend
crows lots but but not but not people
who use Bing people who use Bing what to
befriend normal people
which is particularly surprising because
people use Bing and lastly we learned
don't pee in your humidifier oh yes
don't so glad that we learned that job
otherwise how would we ever have known
John you know what one of my favorite
parts of the week is every week is it
the part where we record this weekend
Ryan's are terrible podcast for patrons
at patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
I was just gonna say that at the part
where we record a podcast but yeah I
mean that's part of it
oh yeah it's also one of my favorite
parts of the week thank you for doing
this with me thanks to everybody for
listening and making it possible thanks
to everybody who supports us on patreon
o allows us to help make the shows we
make it complexly and thanks again to
our sponsor for today's episode
Squarespace again the dear Hank or Dear
John you can pick your favorite organ
just pick randomly and 10% off your
first order thanks again to Squarespace
Hank thank you for plotting with me and
I'm gonna let you read the credits this
podcast is edited by Nicholas Jenkins
it's produced by rosianna halse rojas
and sheridan Gibson Victoria van Giorno
is our head of community and
communications the theme music you are
listening to is from the great
gunnarolla he also does the music for
this week in Ryan's which is available
at patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
where you can find out more about the
baths bombardment compartment and also
about cereal desk granola and also about
how to tie your shoes like Mark and
Sarah thank you all for listening it's
an absolute pleasure and as they say in
our hometown don't forget to be awesome
you
[Music]